onward to Amsterdam and that is a hit
from Amsterdam high six is the name of
that band hy SICS with that regional hit
called made in Amsterdam and that's a
strong you can feel the beat in there
you can feel the undertones and the the
different overtones as well Amsterdam
the Dutch baby the Dutch by far some of
the most aerodynamic people you'll ever
see I mean they're the Dutch are
downhill they're downhill individuals
they will they are in motion IMD baby
the in motion does you don't see a lot
of still Dutch name 70 still does
nobody can brother okay they're in
motion doesn't matter they're on a tram
they're on rollerskates they're so in a
magic carpet and riding on it at the
same time the Dutch are doing things if
you don't have any missiles fill your
freaking Dutch buddy's mouth up with
gunpowder and send him on his way bro
he'll get the job done they are movers
tell someone in amsterdam to keep a
secret no problem there they will never
stop long enough to even share what you
told them
I mean everywhere you go in Amsterdam
there just get it on a train on a bike
on a boat on a bird on a rumor on a
breeze ever it's just
[Music]
the Dutch are coming and going I saw a
dude pass by on a falcon putting on skis
and worried he was going to be late for
a regional avalanche they are on the
move where are you going brother others
a ship you know there's a unicycle
there's a bycicle doxycycline Rocky
Johnson I'm catching him he's headed to
heaven um yeah gotta catch the 5:00
train man to a canoe to a uber pool that
actually drains into a real pool and
it's a whirlpool and then I'm meeting
Joran van der Sloot and hopefully the
Bermuda Triangle will still be open
because we got to be there I can't
believe they let people get high there
okay
there's way too many moving parts it's
almost like trying to smoke a blunt in
the middle of a game of Tetris on
difficult I mean I can't be in high
they're just everywhere there's just
it'd be like being high in a like a in a
conveyor belt Factory bruh I found nah
maybe you know catch me I'll be in the
hammock area but Amsterdam they the
Dutch man I'm set I'm telling you their
aerodynamic for a reason because they're
on the move and look if you see if you
see a Dutch person this is how you see
them that's a Dutch oh what's oh what's
that oh that's a Dutch oh dang oh man
what was it
Oh a Dutch abused what was that oh dang
Oh
[Music]
what solemn is that hail naw that's a
batch of Dutch son the Dutch are coming
and going they're in motion whoa
somebody just pulled the floor out from
under me nah that's the shifts on this
plate tectonic Dutch beautiful city
beautiful people but you got to be ready
to move to move everything's in you know
even the cows there they run and bra
they not graze and they'll chew chew
chew you'll see a cow jump over the moon
dude and do it a couple times that day
yeah everything they're on the go you
get a steak at night there's no meat on
it this cow damn who's just Kyra Lewis
this thing ran right out of his own meat
and the steak be like a damn nugget bro
like a beef Naga you could throw it up
in the air and that's nothing bro you
know you got a mouthful of all Amster
steak stay Dutch baby thank you guys for
checking out this clip and if you want
to see another clip then you can look at
this clip or this clip either one of
these so did you pick one or he's still
just watching me do this cuz it's
alarming